boney m bloggerin kolumnistin autorin
und psychologin am vergangenen sonntag
hat ihre blogger gemeinde zum ersten mal
darüber abgestimmt was sie zu tun hat
dabei wurde klar
boney m beschäftigt sich mit dem
umstrittenen hafenkran und nicht mit dem
traditionellen sexiest die mehrheit
so wird das von ihm in den nächsten zwei
wochen noch häufiger erging im online
demokratie experiment namens ich die
mehrheit können alle per internet
darüber abstimmen wie ihr leben verläuft
boney m die angesagte bloggerin war das
online experiment drei wochen lang lebt
sie die direkte demokratie krise idee
und wir jetzt online gehen und abstimmen
die entscheidung kommen kaffee trinken
hier entscheidet das ziel ist klar
boney m will denkprozesse und
diskussionen anregen und ihrer blogger
gemeinde aufzeigen dass politik schon im
alltag anfängt und sogar spaß machen
kann
als kind vorhanden
konsequenzen muss die direkte demokratie
erst das volk der souverän und fällt
politische entscheidungen auf höchster
ebene wie an einer landsgemeinde
es ist ein relativ junges politisches
system in der schweiz kennt man die
direkte demokratie seit mitte des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts und seither
wird sie immer mal wieder infrage
gestellt
jüngst vom deutschen bundespräsidenten
joachim gauck
die direkte demokratie enthält und birgt
in sich der schöner ansatz der
mitwirkung aller dem wir begrüßen wird
in sich eine große gefahr bei der
richtung bei der beim herausfinden der
richtung bei hochkomplexen politikthemen
andreas glaser rechtswissenschaftler und
leiter des zentrums für demokratie
er weiß warum es immer wieder stimmen
gibt welche die direkte demokratie am
liebsten abschaffen würden oder hat der
deutsche bundespräsident das schweizer
politsystem einfach nur falsch
verstanden
bei waters eine für spielerische und
politiker wovon politiker gewählt ist
und dann würde ich im sinn von
machterhalt natürlich auch so
argumentiere und alles von mir gebe wo
mini autorität in frage stellt und die
direkte demokratie ist halt das
kontrollinstrument politiker und das
gefällt viele politiker
genau aus diesem grund will boney m die
abstimmungs mobile generation dazu
aufrütteln sich stärker in die politik
einzumischen
am besten gleich online dann blüht sich
eventuell weniger informieren wie sie
weniger komitee 10 zudem blüht sie
setzte aber ich glaube dass wir da
passierte massive zunahme pedale um
besucher an der elektronischen
abstimmung wird zwar gearbeitet doch die
rechtlichen voraussetzungen sind noch
mangelhaft
in der zwischenzeit nutzt boney m schon
mal ihren bekanntheitsgrad um die lust
an der politischen debatte zu schüren
alle sind eingeladen zum spielerischen
demokratie training auf es treffpunkt ch
/ ich die mehrheit